كشفت اجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه عن اعتقال
ما وصفتها بانها خليه ارهابيه تعمل لصالح
طهران ويديرها ايراني يقيم في الاردن
واضافت اجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه في بيان
مشترك ان الخليه مكونه من خمسه فلسطينيين
وانها كانت مكلفه باغتيال شخصيات
اسرائيليه بينها وزير الامن القومي اتمار
بن غفير والحاخام اليمني يهودا لليك بحسب
زعمها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ونناقشه في
ثلاثه مسارات ما حقيقه كشف اسرائيل عما
تقول انها خليه تابعه لايران وما دلاله
الخوض في تفاصيل مهمه الخليه المزعومه
واماكن وجود اعضائها واسماء الشخصيات التي
تستهدفها وفي اي سياق ياتي كشف الاجهزه
الاسرائيليه عن ما تقول انها خليه تخريبيه
تخدم طهران وما مغزى توقيت هذا الكشف وما
الجهات التي يمكن ان تستفيد
منها وما تاثير مثل مثل هذا الكشف على
الداخل الاسرائيلي وما يشهده من صراعات
وعلى توجهات اسرائيل ازاء ايران ودول في
المنطقه
في سياق احتجاجات شعبيه مستمره منذ اشهر
في اسرائيل ضد سياسات حكومه اقصى اليمين
وبموازاة
تقول انها خليه تعمل لصالح ايران ويديرها
ايراني مقيم في الاردن ومضى البيان في
اراد معلومات مفصله عما يسميها الخليه
التي قال انها تتكون من خمسه فلسطينيين
ثلاثه منهم من محافظه جنين بالضفه الغربيه
واثنان من داخل الخط الاخضر من دون ان
يغفل ذكرى اسمائهم واعمارهم واماكن
اقامتهم اما عن مهمه الخليه فقد هب البيان
في شرحها ايضا مؤكدا ان اخطر ما اوكل
اليها هو اغتيال شخصيات اسرائيليه عديده
بينهم وزير الامن الداخلي اتمار بن غفير
والحاخام اليميني يهودا جليك وهما من بين
الشخصيات الاشد تطرفا في المشهد
الاسرائيلي والاكثر اثاره للجدل
فيه
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشة
ايهاب جبرين الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي ومن عمان سمير الحباشنه وزير
الداخليه والثقافه الاردني الاسبق وابدا
بضيفي عبر الهاتف ايهاب جبارين تفاصيل
كثيره في هذا الاعلان الاسرائيلي الذي جاء
في بيان مشترك للجيش والشاباك
والشرطه تفاصيل كثيره عن الشخصيات عن
المستهدفين
ا ماذا يقرا في كل هذه التفاصيل ما الذي
يمكن قراءته
نعم مساء الخير مء الخير يعني بدايه يجب
ان ناخذ الامور في سياقها الاول السياق
الاول يجب ان نسير على الاقل في العام
الاخير الثمانيه اشهر الاخيره كان هنالك
الكثير من الكشف عن خلايا متورطه مع جهات
ايرانيه في داخل اسرائيل خلايا ال
فلسطينيه بطبيعه الحال وفي هذا السياق
يمكن القول ان دائما كان هنالك ذلك المشهد
الكلاسيكي ان
تكشف بنوع من الزاعه الاعلاميه حول وجود
هذه الخليه وبسرعه كبيره كذلك يتم التغطيه
عن يعني اساليب عملها وما الى ذلك او او
حتى عن الحدث الاعلامي نفسه يعني بالتالي
هذا كان مشهدا كلاسيكيا
نتذكر ما يخص قبل عده اشهر تورط عصابات
اجرام ب التجاره بالسلاح مع جهات ايرانيه
وقبلها كذلك الوصول الى مفترق مجدو وا
العمليه التي كانت هناك وبالتالي كل هذه
الامور يمكن ربطها ب امر واحد ووحيد هو
سؤال المصداقيه يجب ان نبدا من هناك هل
حقا هذه امور التي تحاول او حدثت على امر
الواقع ام انها مجرد محاولات لما يسمى
بالفشن محاولات اصطياد وبالذات في ظل يعني
تحديدا في ظل يعني بالاسابيع الاخيره كان
هنالك اكثر من مره عن اعلانات من طرف
طهران انها تملك ملفات حساسه بالنسبه لصحه
بنيامين نتنياهو وكذلك ايران بدات يعني
تحاول ان
تلعب مع اسرائيل في الملعب الرمادي
الاستخباراتي على مدى العقود الاخيره
العقدين الاخيرين على الاقل اسرائيل استفر
استفردت عفوا بالمشهد الاستخباراتي مع
طهران والموساد او على الاقل الاجهزه
الاستخباراتيه الايرانيه كان لديها
باعا منفردا بكل ما يخص التعامل مع المساد
التعامل مع
الشاباك التورل لداخل اسرائيل حتى هذه
المرحله هو مشهد لم نرى على ما يبدو
السيناريو الاول وال الذي يجب ان ناخذه
بعين الاعتبار هنالك استشعارات
استخباراتيه اسرائيليه بان هنالك وجود
لخي خلايا حقيقيه ايرانيه في داخل اسرائيل
وهي تحاول اصطيادهم عبر مثل هذه المناورات
هذا السيناريو الاول الذي يمكن ان يكون
اكثر واقعيه من السيناريوهات او على الاقل
من المشاهد التي تطرحها اسرائيل ايه في
واقع الامر يعني يمكن حتى القول ان تكرر
السيناريو الركيك الاحداث يوجد به بعض
الكثير من الشك والريبه يعني في ظل وجود
عصابات اجرام في داخل اسرائيل لديها باعها
الكبير التي يعني الحديث على سبيل المثال
معما يعني كان هنالك عن حرق سيارات يعني
حرق سيارات وامر يحدث بشكل يومي في
اسرائيل بكميات كبيره فالحديث وكان هو
نقطه اضاءه ضوء احمر بالنسبه للشباك هذه
نقطه ربما حقا يجب الوقوف عندها ابقى معنا
سيد ايهاب جبارين كثير من علامات
الاستفهام اذا حول هذا الاعلان الاسرائيلي
وحول
تفاصيله لنرى ان كان ضيفنا ايضا من عمان
السيد سمير الحباشنه يشاركك هذه الشكوك في
الروايه الاسرائيليه بالنسبه لك ما
مصداقيه هذه الروايه استاذ
سمير اسعدتم مساء ومساء الخير على الناصره
والاستاذ ايهاب
ايضا سيدي مثل يعني في نفس ال المنحى اللي
حكى فيه ايهاب من الناصره انا اعتقد ان
اعتدنا على دوله الاحتلال في الاشهر
الاخيره ومنذ ازمه موضوع الانقسام الداخلي
الحاد داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي هو محاوله
للهروب الى الخارج وتحميل الخارج الازمه
الداخليه اللي لها يعني ثنائيه لها جزئين
لها شقين الشق الاول ازمتهم الداخليه
والانقسام الحال في مجتمعهم ما بين من
يريد ان يعيد في الدول ووله الى دوله
دينيه تلمود داعشيه ومن يحاول ان يبقي على
الشكل الليبرالي بحده الادنى في الاطار
اليهودي مع ان الجميع متفق على عنصريه
الدوله تجاه الشعب الفلسطيني هذا جانب
والجانب الثاني من هذه الروايه في سياق
روايات عديده محاوله تشويه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه و لتبدو امام العالم وكانها
والله خلايا ماجوره الى هذه الدوله او تلك
وبتذكر يعني اولا المقصود دائما ايران
والنقطه الثانيه الاردن الاردن تذكر وهنا
في الجزيره ناقشنا قبل اسابيع عندما قالوا
بانه يدخل علينا سلاح مهرب من الاردن
وبالتالي نحن مضطرين ان نعمل هذا الجدار
اللي هو بالطبع يعني خرق للمعاهده
الاردنيه وخرق ايضا للمشروع الفلسطيني في
موضوع الدوله و افهم هذا الامر بانه تحرش
في الاردن نظرا لموقفه الثابت
في الاردن من موضوع الدوله الفلسطينيه
والتمسك في حل الدولتين والقدس والانسحاب
وال 67 كما تعرف انا اعتقد انه محاولات
مستمره ل نتنياهو يصدر ازمته الخارجيه مره
مع ايران مره حزب الله مره بقول غزه بدها
تضرب مره خلايا داخليه مشبوهه مرتبطه
وينسى ان الشعب الفلسطيني يخوض مقاومه
مشروعه بكل الشرعات الدوليه
عندما يضع يخضع شعب الى احتلال فانه
يستخدم كل اساليبه من اجل ان يتحرر وينعت
من الاحتلال انا بعتقد هي محاولات تشويه
المقاومه بالاول وثانيا محاوله لتصدير
ازمه ومحاوله نتنياهو ان يعيد السيطره على
المجتمع الاسرائيلي على اساس ان هناك عدو
خارجي وبالطبع دائما شماعه ايران والى حد
بعيد شماعه الدول التي لا تسير في المشروع
الاسرائيلي الاردن طبعا في حاله سلام مع
اسرائيل
و كيف تنظر الى تضمين الاردن في لائحه
الاتهام التي اعلنها البيان المشترك للجيش
والشرطه وجهاز الامن الداخلي عن
وجود من يدير هذه المجموعه وجود ايراني
داخل الاردن يدير هذه المجموعه ويهرب
السلاح ويصدر التعليمات كيف تنظر الى وجود
مثل هذا العنصر في لائحه
الاتهام صديقي العزيز يعني قلت لك هي حاله
او وضع تحرش مستمر في الاردن باشكال
مختلفه يعني بتتذكر انت حاولوا يضربوا
السفير الاردني ومحاوله لخرق الوصايه
الاردنيه حاولوا يقولوا انه السلاح ياتينا
من الاردن انا بظن هو اشتباك خفي مع
الاردن لاننا لا نسير اطلاقا ولا نوافق
اطلاقا على ما يجري من حكومه الاحتلال
اتجاه الشعب الفلسطيني انا بظن سيدي
الاردن اي وانا خارج المسؤوليه لكنها
واحده من ثوابت الدوله الاردنيه العميقه
ان لا تكون الدوله الاردنيه محطه للاعتداء
على اي جهه خارجيه غير وارد اطلاقا ان
يكون عميل ايراني او رجل ايراني او مكتب
لايران في المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه يعمل
ضد اي دوله في الخارج وبتذكر انت
الاتهامات نعمل ضد سوريا نعمل ضد العراق
نعمل نعمل هذا كلام هو تحرش ومن باب
اي يعني ارسال رسائل بان حكومه الاحتلال
لا ترضى على الموقف الاردني اتجاه القضيه
الفلسطينيه وبربط ذلك حقيقه انا في الخطاب
الاردني والخطاب القطري والخطاب الجزائري
عده خطابات عربيه كانت في الجمعيه
العموميه واضحه وقويه و صارمه اتجاه رفض
اي حل دون دوله فلسطينيه وعاصمتها القدس
وعلى اراضي
67 بظن هو شكل من اشكال اعيد واكرر اه كما
تفضل نعم هنا بالتاكيد هي محاوله للم لمه
الجبهه الداخليه لمل الجبهه انه يا اخوان
بده اقول لهم نتنياهو ان هناك اعداء
خارجيين حتى اصدقائنا الذين لهم او لقول
لا الناس اللي بينهم بينهم معاهده يعملون
او يحاولوا ان يعبث الا الاسرائيلي وهذا
حقيقه غير صحيح هي مقاومه مشروعه للشعب
الفلسطيني غير مرتبطه باي جهه خارجيه هكذا
افهم الامر وهكذا افهم المشهد الفلسطيني
ونعود مره اخرى لايهاب جبارين من الناصره
هنالك ايضا سياق داخلي مظاهرات مستمره منذ
اشهر مثل هذا الاعلان وتوقيت هذا الاعلان
هل له علاقه بما يجري في الداخل و هل له
ان يؤثر
فيه
نعم يعني بدايه نقطه مهمه جدا يعني يجب ان
نقف عندها بمفهوم كهذا او كاخر على المدى
او العام الاخير كان هنالك نوع من الشرخ
بكل ما يخص العلاقات ما بين هذه الحكومه
والاجهزه الامنيه كنوع من التصدعات التي
يعني انبتت من التعديلات القضائيه ومن
قضيه الاحتجاجات ولكن وهي نقطه مهمه جدا
في الايام الاخيره في الاسابيع الاخيره في
الاشهر الاخيره هنالك حديث تام ومهم جدا
وملح اصلا عن نوع من التسويه والمرحله بدا
الحديث عن المرحله ما بعد التعديلات
القضائيه وكيفيه تجاوز هذا الشرخ
وباعتقادي يعني باعتقادي رغم ان حتى لو
كان الحديث هنا عن مجرد محاوله فيشينج
واصطياد او سيناريو من يعني اسرائيلي بكل
ما يخص حتى الشخصيات التي تم تسميتها هي
ليست مصادفه بينج فير و جليك من جهه هم
يعني لا يوجد لديهم اي اهتمام في الاجماع
الاسرائيلي في اجماع الم المشهد
الاسرائيلي عدا عن كونهم شخصيات مهمه لكل
ما يخص اليمين وهذا حتى ما يمكن ان تراه
تحديدا اليوم في ظل كل المشهد و تفكك
المشهد الاسرائيلي يعني هذا لم يتصدر ذلك
الخبر
كانه اقتناص لبين فير او استهدافا لبين
فير حتى يهودا جليك تقريبا لم يذكر في ظل
هذا المشهد بقدر ما هو الوجود الايراني او
التوغل الايراني في ال في داخل المشهد
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي هذه القضيه في نهايه
المطاف حتى الاسامي هي لربما نوع من ايه
اسامي التي يعني مجرد قرابين
تقدمها الاجهزه الامنيه الاحتلالي
الاستخباراتيه وغيرها من جهه ومن جهه كذلك
نقطه مهمه جدا هي محاوله تسويه يعني
محاوله تلميع وجودها الاجهزه الامنيه امام
ال اليمين المتطرف بالذات بعد كل الشرخ
الذي كان على الاقل في ظل الاشهر الاخيره
الثمانيه اشهر الاخير الايره وكذلك في ظل
التوتر هنالك مرحله
توتر رهيبه يمكن القول التي لم يكن لديها
سابق بكل ما يخص الاستخبارات اليهوديه او
الوحده الخاصه باليهود في داخل الشباك مع
يمين الاستيطاني هنالك توتر يعني يعود
للذاكره لسنوات الت0 فب اعتقادي نعم هنالك
نوع من التقارب يمكن القول في ظل مثل هذا
الحدث اسم بين واسم بدون ا شك اليمين ولا
يعني الاجماع الاسرائيلي من اللافت ايضا
هو وجود
فلسطينيين من ابناء
الداخل ماذا ماذا يعني هذا ما الذي يغيره
في
السياقات نعم هي كذلك يعني نقطه مهمه جدا
يجب الوقوف عننا
يعني الاضعف في ظل كل هذا المشهد هم كانوا
هؤلاء الفلسطينيين يعني نحن نتحدث حتى من
ناحيه قدرات حتى من ناحيه جيل حتى حتى من
ناحيه المهام التي القت على عليهم يعني ان
كان القصه حقيقيه او ان كانت من وحي
الخيال ونسجل خيال الاستخبارات
الاسرائيليه هي نقطه يجب الوقوف عندها ان
في نهايه المطاف لا يوجد هنالك واقعيه حتى
للمشهد في ظل مثل هذين الاسمين
يعني نحدث عن شخصيات ع ما يؤشر وجود شخصين
في لائحه الاتها البروفيل يحملان
الفلسطينيان يحملان الجنسيه الاسرائليه ال
الداخل بالنسبه لقضيه الجنسيه هذه النقطه
مهمه جدا هي تكررت بكل ما يخص المشهد
الايراني في كل مره يعني حتى عندما كان
الحديث عن
علاقات بالمتاجره بالاسلحه مع عصابات
اجرام كان الحديث عن مواطنين فلسطينيين من
الداخل عندما كان الحديث كذلك عن ال
الاختراق من الحدود اللبنانيه كان هنالك
مساعده من فلسطين
الداخل لطالما وا وصمت الجهات
الاستخباراتيه
الاسرائيليه الفلسطينيه الداخل بالطابور
الخامس وهذه نقطه مهمه جدا يعني لكي وضعهم
وتوقعهم في داخل وتطيره في داخل هذا
المشهد بكل ما يخص علاقتها مع فلسطيني
الداخل هذا بدايه وهذه جدا يجب ان نقف
عندها خط بنفير وجلك و سموتريتش
ويخدم هذا الخطاب الخطاب الذي ينظر
للفلسطينيين جميعا على انهم الغير مرحبين
في كل فلسطين لكن استاذ سمير الحباشنه
فيما يتعلق بمن يستفيد من هذه التفاصيل
واعلانها بهذا الشكل من في رايك يستفيد من
ذلك هي رساله لداخل كما ذكرت لك هذا مجتمع
الاسرائيلي اليوم مجتمع منقسم طولان
انشطار رهيب صدع مثل الزلازل منقسم على
نفسه يعني مرشح هذا الانقسام على اي
احتمال من احتمالات المواجهه م مهمه
الاجهزه ومهمه اليمين ومهمه نتنياهو
وزمرته ان يحاولوا توحيد هذا المجتمع وعلى
شروطهم يعني اي سحب ما يمكن سحبه من
الديمقراطيه خلق دوله يهوديه المديه بكل
ما تعني الكلمه وبنفس الوقت رساله بان كل
الفلسطينيين سواء في الضفه او في الداخل
او في غزه هم في خندق العداء لهذه الدوله
وايضا مثل ما ذكرت لك يجدوا في فزاعه
ايران دائما سبب لتوحيد الداخل وبعتقد هي
مساله سطحيه
ومكشوفه ولن تعطي اكلها لانها لن تؤثر على
طبيعه الشعب الفلسطيني كشعب مقاوم مقاومته
مشروعه بقولوا حرق سيارات انا في كل
انتفاضات الشعب الفلسطيني لم يلجا الشعب
الفلسطيني في الضفه الغربيه لحرق سيارات
على العكس هم يحاولوا بهذه المقاومه اللي
غلبها سلميه التعبير عن حقهم في الانعتاق
وفي قيام الدوله وهو مشروع معترف فيه في
كل على مستوى كل العالم سوف نسمع اي يعني
في هذا السياق سوف نسمع الكثير من يعني
الادعاءات الصهيونيه التي تصب جميعها الان
بانهم يريدوا ان يتوحدوا يوحدوا مجتمع
منشط قسم على نفسه يبحث عن عدو دائما
خارجي حتى يتوحدوا من اج طيب هذا العدو
الخارجي دائما كان كان ايران كما تفضلت
ايهاب الشماعه ايرانيه و صير انها بتصير
الشماعه اردنيه ايضا في الاخير يعني المره
الماضيه كما تذكر قصه التهريب الاسلحه
واليوم بيقولوا ان الايراني مقيم في
الاردن وانا اعتقد انه كلام عاري عن الصحه
طيب فيما يتعلق بهذه الشماعات ايهاب ايهاب
جبارين سبق غير مره ان اعلنت اسرائيل وان
لم يكن بهذا التفصيل وبهذه المعلومات
المفصله
عن تجنيد ايرانيين لنساء اسرائيليات
للحصول على معلومات عن كذا وكذا وكذا وغير
ذلك من المحاولات ومؤامرات ايرانيه
لاغتيال شخصيات اسرائيليه سواء في الداخل
او في الخارج لكن كل هذه المحاولات
اذا كان الهدف منها هل الهدف منها هو
توحيد الداخل فعلا ام الهدف منها تهيئه
الجو لعمل ماد
الدايره هنالك نقطه مهمه جدا يجب ان
اتذكرها ربما اريد ان اربطها كذلك يعني مع
ضيفك الكريم بما تفضل به مؤخرا ايه قضيه
البارانويا يعني لطالما التماسك
الاسرائيلي لكل هذا المجتمع بدون ادنى شك
المتفكك في ظل هذه المرحله كان لديه
البارانويا وهنا نقطه مهمه جدا و ربما
بهذه الاستراتيجيه هنالك اصلا توافق ما
بين رؤيه بنيامين نتنياهو وما بين رؤيه
الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه البارانويا
على مدى سنوات عديده كانت البارانويا من
الوجود الفلسطيني بنيامين نتنياهو على مدى
ال 15 عام الاخيره عمل جاهدا على امر واحد
ووحيد محو الوجود الفلسطيني محو القضيه
الفلسطينيه محو المقاومه الفلسطينيه محو
الشرعيه الفلسطينيه بكل معنى الكلمه
وبالتالي هو كان بحاجه لبانو جديده
البارانويا الايرانيه ولكن ماذا يعمل بكل
ما يقوم في داخل
اروقه فلسطين من مقاومه من وجود فلسطيني
كيف يمكن ربطه اصلا واو كيف يمكن اختزاله
فكان من السهل او من الحري ربط كل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه المتواجده في داخل
تخوم الاراضي الفلسطينيه من النهر الى
البحر ربطها بال الوجود الايراني وبتمويل
الايراني وبتكتك الايراني وباي
استراتيجيات ايرانيه وبالتالي هذا
ه حتى ما وصل اليه قبل اسبوع هل هذا ينطلي
على الداخل يعني هل هل الداخل يمكن هل هل
الداخل جاهز لتصديق ذلك
بالض هنا قضيه مهمه جدا على يعني هنالك
نوع من الاجماع حتى اصلا لو تعاملنا مع
الاسقاطات يعني بنيامين نتنياهو حاول ان
يتعامل في اكثر من مرحله في الثمانيه اشهر
الاخيره في ظل ازمته ان يلقي باسقاط ازمته
على عدوان على الوجود الفلسطيني ان كان في
غزه وان كان في جنين في اكثر من مرحله هذه
اللعبه هذا التكتيك ضد الفلسطيني لم ينطلي
ما يجمع ال هنالك اجماع من اي عدوان او
عفوا من ع استهداف خارجي ممكن ان يكون ضد
اسرائيل لكن لطالما الامور تتعلق باراضي
ال ما بين النهر والبحر فهي عليها اجماع
وكانها امر
طذ يتون معانها اش داخليه واظن ان
استراتيجيه بنيامين نتنياهو يجب ان نقولها
بخفض اسهم القضيه الفلسطينيه بمفهوم وذه
نقطه مهمه جدا مساله خفض اسهم هو قال لا
نريد لا نريد الفلسطينيين ان يكون لهم حق
النقد او حق الفيتو على اتفاقات السلام
الاسرائيليه مع الدول العربيه استاذ استاذ
سمير
الحباشنه هذا هذا المسعى مسعى لتطبيع مع
دول عربيه دون حل القضيه
الفلسطينيه ه ما حدث اليوم يخدم هذا
التوجه ابدا انا بعتقد بالعكس هم برسائلهم
الداخليه الان ومحاوله
يعني يعني ان تبدوا المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وال الشعب الفلسطيني المقاوم وانه مرتبط
في تلك الجهه او هذه الجهه او تل انا
بعتقد هي محاوله بائسه ولن تؤثر على الامر
وعلى يعني تقديري الشخصي انا انه الان
مرحله حساسه جدا واضح كان في خطابه
نتنياهو في الجمعيه العامه وكانه راكب على
صحو صهوه حصان عربي يعني اننا يمكن ان
نطبع مع العرب دون ان نلتفت الى
الفلسطينيين الفلسطينين سوف ياتوا رغما
عنهم نشكرك شكرا جزيلا للاسف
سيرش وزير الداخليه والثقافه الاردنيه
شكرا لك من عمان ونشكر ضيفنا من الناصره
ايهاب جبارين المحلل السياسي والخبير في
الشان
الاسرائيليين نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج
مراء الخبر في ام
الله